أنت تعلم أنه يعرف أنه متأكد من أنه يستطيع هز
هذا الفتى الطيب ولكن هذا الكلب ذو الأذن الواحدة لديه
حيل أفضل في جعبته كيف
تصف أسلوبه الفني
المجرد جدًا اسمه فان جوخ
بعد الفنان الذي قطع أذنه فان
جوخ كان الكلب  تم إنقاذ
أذنه من كلب يقاتل في ولاية كارولينا الشمالية
في مثل هذا الشكل السيئ ، وكان لابد من بتر أذنه ،
لكن من المؤكد أنها لم تقطع مسيرته
المهنية كفنان
يرسم نسخته من
ليلة فان جوخ الأخرى المرصعة بالنجوم ، مؤسس
هابيلي فور إيفر بعد الإنقاذ في
يضع كونيتيكت كتلًا من الطلاء على
قماش ثم ينزلق إلى كيس زيبلوك
مغطى بزبدة الفول السوداني ، لذا فإن
رسمه هو لعق
زبدة الفول السوداني وأثناء قيامه بلعق
زبدة الفول السوداني ، كل الدهانات التي تعرفها
تلطخ حولها
وتصنعها وتصنعها.  التحفة ولكن عندما
كان لدى فان جوخ معرض غاليري لجمع
الأموال وربما يجد له منزلًا دائمًا ،
ظهر شخصان فقط ، ومع ذلك
، فإن التعاطف والدعاية جعل فان جوخ
نجمًا فنيًا هزليًا قام ببيعه 30  يعمل
بمتوسط ​​40 دولارًا للقطعة
الواحدة ، لكن هذا المزيج الملاكم بيتبول البالغ من العمر سبعة أعوام والذي يبلغ 75 رطلاً
لا يزال بحاجة إلى منزل سيحب
شخصًا
يحتضنه لأنه طفل يحتضن هذا الفنان
وقد يشعر بالملل من كرة لكنه
يحب قطع لحم الخنزير المقدد.  الذهاب مع
نوع التدفق من
كلبه فان جوخ مع تدفق نعم
جيني ماوس
سي إن إن نيويورك